first a cartel associate Brokers the
sale and shipment of fentanyl precursor
chemicals principally from China the
clandestine labs in Mexico where the
fentanyl is manufactured cartels
traffickers move fentanyl from Mexico
into the United States where it is sold
wholesale to other criminal
organizations
before resale those criminal
organizations often mix fentanyl powder
into other drugs such as cocaine and
heroin they also often sell fentanyl
pills as counterfeit prescription pain
medications
and that was attorney general Merrick
Garland on Friday after the justice
department charged 28 members of
Mexico's Sinaloa drug cartel and a
massive investigation into fentanyl
trafficking into communities across the
United States meanwhile the treasury
Department sanctioned two Chinese
companies for providing the chemicals
needed to manufacture that fentanyl this
comes as over 35 thousand pounds of
fentanyl have been seized over the last
three fiscal years with Untold more
making its way across the southern
border undetected in Arkansas Republican
Governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders signed a
bill last week which could charge drug
dealers with aggravated murder if they
knowingly deliver fentanyl that results
in an overdose facing a minimum sentence
of 20 years in prison if convicted
joining me right now is the woman
herself Arkansas governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who will mark 100 days in office
this upcoming Wednesday Governor
congratulations on 100 days good to have
you this morning
thanks so much for having me on Maria
and you've got a lot to celebrate from
education to this crime stance let's
talk about these bills that you signed
into law Arkansas's death by delivery
act I want to get your take on the
significance of this fentanyl killing
Americans right now
you know if the Biden Administration I'm
glad to see that they're finally
stepping up and doing something to crack
down because the breakdown at the border
has allowed in fentanyl to pour into our
country and we are seeing the impact in
communities across the country and
because they have allowed this to take
place states are having to step up and
crack down ourselves and that's exactly
what we did here in Arkansas we passed
legislation this first session of mine
to crack down on drug dealers
specifically targeting those who are
trafficking fentanyl if you knowingly uh
traffic fentanyl that causes an overdose
you will now be charged with murder and
if you traffic fentanyl to kids you can
also be charged with a life sentence so
we are cracking down where the Biden
Administration has failed to actually
step up and I think we're going to see a
lot of States doing exactly this because
it's become so necessary with the out of
control drug problem that we're seeing
everywhere in our country right now well
I mean you have come at this from a
leadership standpoint as a governor as a
woman as a mother and you've attacked
not just the crime crisis and Fentanyl
crisis but also education you see this
as your biggest accomplishment in this
first 100 days right education
absolutely we passed what I think is the
most Historic Landmark Education
legislation certainly in my state of
Arkansas but probably anywhere in the
country where we went from being the
lowest in teacher pay we were number 48
in the country to top five where we
focused on empowering parents and making
sure that they have the ability to
decide where and how their kids can best
be educated we're putting real resources
into our schools and I think we are
bringing about transformational change
when it comes to education here in
Arkansas that can be a blueprint for
every state in the country yeah
media and
we have we have have had a very busy
first 100 days in office we also passed
legislation that would require parental
consent for any new user on social media
under the age of 18. we have seen the
absolute just damage that social media
is causing to our young people with
anxiety depression suicide rates
skyrocketing and among teens in large
part due to social media we want to get
more kids off screens protect them from
the dangers frankly I'd love to see them
off screens more and outside a whole lot
if we can change the way that our
culture is focusing but really putting
that power back into the hands of
parents so that they know what their
kids are doing and protecting them for
the Long Haul well that
turn to try to ban tick tock
unless the country we're doing it but
it's unlikely in my mind that the
Democrats are really going to ban
Tick-Tock because it's a tool to attract
young people I mean even as Governors
were talking about banning Tick Tock
Alexandro ocasio-cortez did a video on
tick tock
I think we've seen that Democrats
priority is a lot more about building
their voter base than it is about
protecting our country we've seen that
time and time again I don't expect that
they're going to take meaningful action
on things like Banning Tick Tock which
is again why we've had to count on
Governors to step up we ban Tick Tock
from all government devices here in the
state of Arkansas I know a number of
other states have done that as well and
I think that you're going to continue to
see Conservative Republican Governors
step up where the federal government
constantly fails well it's also
seeing Republican Governors uh also
take on now this has been more
bipartisan than some people know because
the committee on communist China is
headed by Mike Gallagher a republican
but there are also Democrats who
understand the threat tell me about that
surveillance threat and the CCP wanting
to buy more land near our military
installations what are you doing about
it
we have passed a number of pieces of
legislation to push back against the
infringement of the Chinese government
whether it's Banning tick tock on our
state devices uh Banning the use of
Chinese drones here in the state as well
as Banning the purchase of land here in
Arkansas by a company majority majority
owned by the Chinese government so we
are looking for every place we can to
push back from the Chinese government
infringement here in our country and I
know a number of other states that are
are following suit we're going to
continue to lead on this issue and I
hope that the federal government will as
well Governor it's great to have you
congratulations to you on 100 days and
we hope you'll come back soon
absolutely thanks so much for having me
Maria always a pleasure to see you thank
you so much NTU Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else